- [Narrator] Clinical
trials for COVID-19 vaccines
are nearing the final stretch.
But health experts say
vaccines are just one piece
of a larger puzzle in
fighting the deadly disease
and getting us back to normal.
The other big piece are
effective treatments
for those who are a%lready sick.
- Not everybody mounts
a good immune response,
in particular immunosuppress
patients are well-known
to not to respond well to vaccines.
So we are gonna need to have therapies
for those who are not vaccinated
and for those who don't
make a good immune response.
- [Narrator] Right now, there
are three main categories
of COVID-19 treatments:
antibody therapies,
immunomodulators, and antivirals.
Antibody therapies leverage
antibodies, like these,
that the body naturally produces
after recovering from a disease.
To ward off infection,
they attach to proteins
on the viruses surface.
That prevents it from infiltrating cells.
Different types of antibodies target
different parts of the virus.
They circulate in the
yellowish liquid part of blood
known as plasma.
That's where the treatment comes in.
- You can take that liquid
and give it to a person
who's sick or to prevent disease.
So it is the transfer of immunity
from a person who's made it
to a person who's susceptible.
- [Narrator] When given to sick patients,
convalescent plasma can potentially boost
a person's immune response to the virus,
but just for a few weeks.
- We always pull it out during a pandemic.
We did this for 2009 H1N1,
obviously for things such as
Ebola virus disease in Africa.
- [[Narrator] Because it's
relatively easy to produce
compared to vaccines and other drugs,
experts think it could possibly
be used both as a treatment
and as a preventative
medicine against COVID-19.
- It's based on the same principle
of if you have a protective antibody,
passive transfer of that could
provide not only protection
prophylactically but also treatment.
- [Narrator] Plasma is
widely thought to be safe,
and in August the FDA authorized using it
to treat patients
hospitalized with COVID-19.
But its effectiveness
is still being studied.
- Convalescent plasma
is a little bit of a,
it's a mixed bag.
We don't actually know
the titers of the patients
who have survived and
done well after COVID.
- [Narrator] Titers are a
measurement of how many antibodies
are in a person's blood.
Typically, the more
antibodies a person has,
the better chance they have
at fighting an infection.
This means that not all
plasma is created equal.
The amount and quality of
antibodies it contains can vary.
That impacts how effective
the treatment can be.
- Getting with convalescent
plasma right now
is a bit of an unknown.
- [Narrator] To overcome this,
scientists use plasma as a blueprint
to build a more potent drug
known as monoclonal antibodies.
They do this by homing
in on specific antibodies
that do the best job
in stopping the virus.
- We screen these huge
panels of antibodies
through many in vitro assays
to select the best antibiotics
that block the ability of
the virus to get inside cells
and infect them.
- [Narrator] Once they're identified,
scientists can mass produce them
in facilities that resemble breweries
and pack them into drugs
that act as a targeted attack
against the virus.
- You're growing these
cells in bioreactors,
which are huge steel tanks,
and then as the cells grow,
they are pumping out antibody.
You are concentrating
that, and in purified form,
this is what you are
administering to patients.
- [Narrator] Both Regeneron
and competitor Eli Lilly
have been racing to bring
monoclonal antibody drugs
to market for COVID-19.
The companies are testing
drugs that contain one
or two types of antibodies,
and researchers say
they could have benefits
over plasma-based treatments.
- Monoclonal antibody
preparations are consistent.
They are consistent
from patient to patient.
They can be standardized,
and they are hopefully
easier to use than plasma
because of its properties.
- [Narrator] Each of the
companies has released
encouraging data from
early stage clinical trials
showing their drugs help
reduce coronavirus levels
and improved symptoms in
non-hospitalized patients.
But both drug makers had
to pause their studies
in hospitalized patients,
and the Lilly study was halted
in this patient population altogether
because they didn't see a benefit.
Early data among less severe
patients though looks promising
for both drugs.
In October, President Trump was given
Regeneron's antibody cocktail
as part of his COVID-19 treatment.
The president said the drug
was key to his recovery,
but it's unclear how beneficial
the drug actually was.
- I just wanna say we have Regeneron.
We have a very similar
drug from Eli Lilly.
And they're coming out and
we're trying to get them
on an emergency basis.
- [Narrator] Both Regeneron
and Lilly have asked the FDA
to authorize emergency
use of their treatments.
- We have committed to
manufacturing about 300,000 dose
of these antibodies by
the end of this year,
And we have also partnered with those
so that we can scale up and produce
about 2 million dose of these antibodies
to be available annually
for worldwide use.
- [Narrator] But physicians
have expressed concerns
about these new drugs.
- This isn't the type of
drug that is always able
to be scaled, that can be made
available to everyone rapidly
and also is a low cost
- [Narrator] Experts say both plasma
and monoclonal antibody
treatments could help
not just COVID-19 patients
but also help prevent
infection in healthy people.
To treat patients,
doctors have also been
using immunomodulators.
These drugs suppress the immune system
and ensuing inflammation in the sickest
of COVID-19 patients.
That's important because this
inflammation can be deadly.
One of those drugs is the
steroid Dexamethasone.
Researchers have found
that it improves survival
when given to severely ill patients.
The other treatment being
used to fight COVID-19
is the antiviral drug Remdesivir.
This was another drug
the president was given
at Walter Reed Hospital.
- So we really try to give
Remdesivir as soon as somebody
may be admitted to the hospital.
We wanna give it as early as possible.
We know from Tamiflu and the flu
and all those kinds of different drugs
that giving antivirals
sooner rather than later
is really important.
- [Narrator] Here's how
it stops the coronavirus.
When a virus infects a cell,
it uses the cell's machinery
to build more viruses.
It does that by making copies of its RNA.
That's the genetic material
that contains instructions
for replication.
Remdesivir is designed to
infiltrate these instructions
by inserting itself into copies
of the viruses genetic code.
This interrupts the replication process
and acts as a kill switch for the virus.
Promising clinical trials led
to the drug being approved
for emergency use in May,
but more recent studies have
produced conflicting results
about its ability to speed up recovery
and curve death in COVID-19 patients.
The Department of Health
and Human Services
allowed drug maker
Gilead to market the drug
directly to hospitals in October.
And the CEO said he was confident
in being able to deliver
the drug to the patients who need it.
- We now have enough supply
of this medicine for patients
in the United States and globally
by the end of this month.
- [Narrator] There's
been tremendous progress
in treating COVID-19 but
health experts caution
that there is still more work to be done
to see just how effective
these treatments are.
And to save lives, doctors
will need a multitude of drugs
at their disposal.
- I think that we're gonna
see many more therapeutics
come out by the end of this pandemic,
and so that people that enter
the hospital will at least
receive one specific COVID-19
treatment for their disease.
- [Narrator] Experts say these
three types of treatments
are promising and they are
hopeful that therapeutic drugs
combined with a vaccine may finally put up
an effective defense against the pandemic.
(upbeat instrumental music)